the movie is set in a dystopian 2024
where the world is still suffering from
the coronavirus in fact the virus has
mutated and has transformed into a
deadlier form known as kovid 23 people
have been staying indoors for 215 weeks
but despite this the mortality rate has
gone up to 56
everyone is compelled to go through a
daily virus test which is conducted via
an application if they fail the
sanitation department will forcefully
take them to the quarantine zone aka q
zone rumors say that whosoever enters
the q zone never returns the whole
country is going through a curfew and
people are restricted from coming out of
their houses if they do not comply they
are shot on sight the scene then shifts
to a delivery boy nico who is riding
around on his bicycle delivering the
packages he is roaming so freely as he
is wearing a yellow armband which
denotes that he is immune to the disease
however he can still transfer it to
others nico works for a man named lester
who runs a courier company that serves
wealthy people on the other hand we are
introduced to a wealthy woman piper
griffin who lives in a lavish house with
her husband william and daughter emma
like any other kid affected by the
lockdown emma is always alone and
desires to have a friend however piper
refuses the request mentioning that it
is not safe for emma since she is
suffering from an autoimmune disorder
following this the mother-daughter duo
takes the virus test and passes it with
flying colors at the same time nico
arrives at their door to deliver some
packages he passes the packages through
a uv sanitation machine and in return
receives a generous tip from piper after
delivering the packages nico returns
home and talks to his girlfriend sarah
who lives with her mother lita in her
apartment nico and sarah have not met
each other in person as sarah is forced
to stay indoors and is bound to take
care of her grandmother here we get to
know that niko is actually saving up to
buy a yellow immunity band illegally for
sarah so they can get out of the city to
live a life of their own although buying
such bans illegally is considered a
punishable offense nico is willing to
risk it all for the love of his life in
the next scene we are introduced to a
famous female singer mae who is doing
one of her live sessions as she is
taking song requests from her fans a
disabled war veteran michael dozer who
also happens to work for lester as a
drone operator tips her 100 and messages
her he mentions that her songs helped
him during his time in the war this
touches may and she sings a motivational
song for him after the session mae calls
dozer and inquires about his war
experiences as dozer explains everything
in detail the two develop a special bond
between them on the other hand nico
visits sarah's apartment and delivers
her a packet of pencils as she loves to
sketch he also gives her a letter where
he has written a funny poem for her
later at night while sarah and nico are
video chatting on their phones lita
approaches sarah and informs her that
she is feeling sick expectedly she
becomes scared but nico assures her that
he will arrive there soon just then the
sanitation department knocks at her door
outside the head of the sanitation
department harlan finds a man who has
escaped from the queue zone and stabs
him to death as sarah prepares for the
worst harland arrives outside the door
and tells his men that they have come to
the wrong door following this the crew
enters a nearby apartment and forcefully
drags a patient out to the queue zone at
the same time nico takes out his
motorbike and rushes to sarah's
apartment after arriving he consoles
sarah by mentioning that everything will
be fine however she requests that he go
back as they might get into trouble if
they are caught despite this nico
insists on keeping an eye on sarah from
outside the door when she finally agrees
the two spend the whole night talking
about their special moments on the other
hand piper's husband william is
preparing to leave the house late at
night surprisingly when he approaches
the door he is confronted by his wife
who asks him where he is going william
says that he has a meeting but piper is
skeptical about that still she lets him
leave but not before telling him to burn
his clothes before he re-enters the
house in the next scene william arrives
at may's residence and the two have some
fun together william is a piece of [ __ ]
after the happy hour william returns to
his home and as urged by his wife burns
his clothes before entering the house
the next day while nico is still
sleeping at her doorstep sarah goes to
leeda for their regular virus checkup at
first she gets herself checked and comes
out clean free of virus but
unfortunately when she does a scan on
lita the application detects some virus
and suggests li to be taken to the
quarantine zone nico also gets to know
about this and tries to persuade sarah
to escape with him however sarah refuses
the request and tells him that she
cannot leave lita in this condition and
go away she also tells him that this
might be their last meeting as the
sanitation forces will arrive any time
soon nico is devastated hearing all this
but he still doesn't want to give up he
informs sarah that he will get some
immunity passes anyhow and leaves the
building following this he makes a call
to lester and asks him if he can manage
two immunity passes for sarah and her
grandmother lester tells him that he
does not have any passes but knows
someone who can arrange them he then
tells nico about the griffin family who
are the immunity past dealers in the
city in the next scene nico arrives at
the griffin residence and talks with
william about the passes hearing this
the griffins are shocked as they wonder
how a commoner knows about their secret
they tell nico that they don't deal in
such illicit things but the latter
starts begging with no options left
piper tells nico that she has run out of
the bands but she does know someone who
stores them in abundance she then hands
him an address and tells him to reach
the place as soon as possible in the
next scene nico arrives at the given
address and enters an abandoned building
to meet the dealer while he is roaming
around the place he is greeted by
harland disguised as an immunity banned
contractor he tries to extract
information about the girl for whom nico
is trying to get the band with harland
continuously asking for some personal
information about the girl nico gets
suspicious and halts from providing him
with further information this enrages
harland and he stabs nico with a
pocketknife but the latter hits him back
and somehow manages to escape from the
place elsewhere as sarah goes to check
on lita she finds her dead devastated
she immediately calls nico and briefs
him on the situation with time running
out nico dresses his wounds and suggests
sarah hides somewhere when the
sanitation department arrives to take
lida's body away on the other hand mae
is talking with dozer and telling him
everything about griffin and his illegal
immunity band business she also tells
him that griffin is using her to fulfill
his desires and that she can no longer
tolerate him hearing this dozer suggests
she be bold and confront the guy rather
than being suppressed by him in the
meantime may gets a message from william
mentioning that he wants to meet her
again at night this time may declines
his request and tells him that
everything between them is over seeing
the messages william becomes mad and
immediately calls may he berates her for
being an immoral person but may counters
by blackmailing him saying that she'll
reveal his illicit business if he
doesn't stop calling her she then cuts
the call short leaving william worried
and stressed as he should be
surprisingly the entire conversation
between the duo is heard by piper in the
next scene as william comes out of his
room he is confronted by piper she
points a gun at him and mentions that
she already knows about his affair piper
then kicks her husband out of the house
as it is the only way to keep their
daughter safe after william leaves piper
calls may to warn her about william
arriving at her place to attack her
terrified mae immediately calls dozer
and asks him if she can come over to his
place and stay without thinking twice
dozer accepts to help her and lets her
stay at his place meanwhile the
sanitation department arrives outside
sarah's apartment when the staff starts
searching for sarah inside the house she
hides in the bathroom and picks up a
baseball bat harland is also among the
group and he continuously asks her to
reveal herself right then sarah attacks
one of the staff and knocks him
unconscious she then wears his hazmat
suit and walks out of the building
without being recognized in the
following scene an enraged nico breaks
into the griffin residence and starts
searching for the immunity bracelets
lester is shocked to see nico's current
location on his gps so he calls piper
and informs her about the situation
scared piper takes her daughter emma to
the bathroom and prepares to face nico
with a gun moments later nico is
confronted by an armed piper who
threatens him to leave nico tells her
that he is not there to expose their
business but to find help for his love
hearing this piper puts her gun down and
takes out a briefcase which contains
several immunity bands she then opens
her laptop and programs a bracelet
before handing it to nico with his
mission finally accomplished nico thanks
piper and rushes out of the building to
meet sarah the scene then shifts to may
who is packing her belongings to leave
the place before william arrives dozer
also takes out his military drone and
flies it towards mae's location
meanwhile mae puts her belongings inside
her car and tries to start it but fails
just then william arrives and threatens
her to get out of the car when she does
not comply he breaks the car door and
grabs her by her neck luckily dozer
manages to locate the duo and using his
sniping skills he shoots william dead
with the drone and saves may god damn
dozer goes hard meanwhile sarah who
tried to escape wearing the hazmat suit
is captured by harland and his crew
although she has yet to develop any
symptoms of coronavirus she is forced to
go to the q zone after some time niko
arrives at sarah's apartment and becomes
worried when he can't find her
surprisingly he is then confronted by
harland who is waiting there for his
arrival he tries to attack nico again
with his pocket knife but this time nico
picks up sarah's sketch pencil and stabs
him on his neck harlan loses a lot of
blood and dies on the spot that ought to
teach him to get a bigger knife while
leaving the apartment nico comes upon
sarah's mobile phone and finds a picture
of the sanitation department vehicle in
which she is being transported to the q
zone he then immediately calls lester
and asks him to locate the vehicle in
turn lester calls dozer and urges him to
find the vehicle lester is lazy with
lester and dozer connected to him on his
mobile phone nico takes out his bike and
drives around the place after some time
dozer spots the sanitation vehicle and
informs nico about the location
desperate to save sarah nico speeds up
to the place and manages to arrive there
before sarah is taken inside the q zone
the police officers try to stop nico but
he somehow manages to come near sarah
and secretly hand her the yellow
immunity bracelet following this the
officers apprehend nico but when they
notice the yellow armbands on the duo
they decide to scan them after a
thorough checkup both nico and sarah are
found to be immune and hence they are
released in the next scene the couple
finally embrace each other for the first
time in their lives just then sarah
reveals that she is also immune like him
she also mentions that the only reason
she didn't get out of her apartment was
because she feared for her grandmother's
life although nico is shocked he
understands her situation and forgives
her in the final scene of the movie
piper and may team up and frame william
and harland as the ones behind the
illegal wristband sales dozer and may
start dating virtually while nico and
sarah are traveling up the pacific coast
highway the movie ends with lester
receiving an immunity bracelet sent to
him by nico as a gift for helping him
out in the toughest of times subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching